the pandemic has forced many businesses
to make tough decisions that includes
one person
who changed operations to help
unemployed entertainers find work
8 news now reporter kristen drummond has
more on the efforts to help
this business is in the historic
commercial center on sahara near
maryland
it opened in june after adapting to the
covet 19
situation and after the owner noticed a
need in the community
[Music]
rita lim gets ready for her show
i'm doing a tribute to the carpenters
she takes the stage inside the vegas
room
an intimate supper club giving lim and
other local performers a place to work
entertainer right now is suffering a lot
because not everybody is employed
but this spot aims to change that it's a
platform of hope
for so many talented people in this city
to come and do what they do best come on
in
tom michelle is president of the venue
he says last year forced him to change
the business model and
recognize a need vegas room actually was
going to be a catering
business until covet hit there was so
much despair when it came to the
entertainment community and
so many talented people in this city
following the governor easing pandemic
restrictions
the vegas room to open giving performers
a chance to work again
in person after finding success
the owners are expanding a few doors
down the nevada room is about seven
thousand square feet
about a little less than half of it is
going to be dedicated to a piano bar
bistro
crews continue remodeling the space from
a former mexican restaurant
when done michelle says the three venues
plan to center around
one idea local entertainment with a
business that was built
for locals that allows lim and others to
share their talents
michelle expects the piano bistro to
open soon and
the nevada room in early summer
reporting in the newsroom i'm kristen
drummond 8 news now